this solidifies him as one of our great
directors of this generation
Whoever has that kid wins the war
what do you want sweetie for robots to
be free
let's talk the Creator all right I've
seen this movie a couple weeks ago and
I'm still thinking about this film it is
a masterpiece of cinema this is one of
the best films of 2023 in my personal
opinion and other people who have given
their first reactions on Twitter have
said as much it is a breath of fresh air
being an original story it has not taken
off some novels or comic books or
anything else like that or a remake of a
movie of years past this is Gareth
Edwards original story he co-wrote it he
directed it he produced this is his baby
and I'm gonna tell you something if you
thought he was a great director watching
Star Wars Rogue one or even Godzilla for
that matter
this solidifies him as one of our great
directors of this generation this guy
he's nailed it and if Kevin feige isn't
given him a call by now or Kathleen
Kennedy is asking him to come back and
do another Star Wars film I don't know
what's wrong with him because honestly
speaking
he has proven himself that he can handle
science fiction he can handle visual
effects he can handle big budgets in a
way where it has storied as heart it has
purpose it's not all about Flash wham
bam you know all these crazy special
effects and it's light on story or light
on character this film
from the moment you start watching it
is just full of story and he brings you
into this world that he's created so
well it is so detailed so well versed
but it doesn't lose you it's not trying
to be smarter than you it's not trying
to be this intellectual film that happy
audience will not get no what he does in
a very interesting way is he reminds me
a lot of James Cameron when Cameron
directs his films if you watch
Terminator or Avatar or True Lies for
that matter you know James Cameron if
you look at the surface his films are a
lot of fun some of the stories could be
simplistic in many people's eyes and
it's just an enjoyable ride to the movie
theaters right but if you go a little
bit deeper and you see the nuances that
James Cameron brings to his stories
especially Avatar or Terminator for that
matter there's a lot more going on there
and Garrett Edwards has that in his
directing in his story telling you see
that more so than ever here in the
Creator I don't want to spoil this film
for you because there are so many twists
and turns I thought it was gonna be like
District 9 or Apocalypse Now or you know
or other films we might have seen in the
past and yes it has Essences of some of
those films but it's so original in its
own right and yes it deals with AI and
humanity and we might say well I've seen
these AI films before
not like this you haven't especially in
this day and age where AI is so relevant
in our society how we navigate on our
computers on our smartphones how we're
getting around the world how we're using
AI to
simplify our lives and you're not going
to push a button or flip the switch and
turn it off it's not going anywhere it's
going to get smarter it's going to
improve and as you see in this film it
is amongst us it's living amongst us it
is part of us now some in this film
you're going to see don't agree with
that and some embrace it and that is a
question that when you walk out of this
theater you're going to have those same
conversations with your friends and your
family and other people who've watched
this film is how much are we going to
embrace AI Isaiah should be afraid of it
or should we be fearful of it or should
we embrace it or or just take it day by
day I there's gonna be many different
questions and you're not going to have
the answers and neither does this film
give you an answer it just gives you two
sides of the story and lets you as the
audience decide where this technology is
going and how far we want it to go and
should we stop it or should we let it
continue to grow and emerge as something
even Beyond mankind
very deep thoughts right there very very
deep questions and very deep
conversations and that's what this film
gives us as an audience now let's talk
about some of the performances here John
David Washington is Denzel Washington's
son some of you may know that some of
you don't I knew him from Ballers the
HBO series with join The Rock Johnson I
loved him in that series he's had a lot
of the other films since then tenet is
one of them with Christopher Nolan he's
fantastic in this movie he is solidified
himself as a star
he has essence of his father that you're
going to hear in the voice and is acting
but he's also has another he has a
different type of energy that is
refreshing and it's exciting to watch
and he's very organic in his his
performance and it's he's just great
he's absolutely awesome his chemistry
with Gemma Chan is fantastic as well and
even the young girl now her name is
Madeline universe and she is gonna be I
mean she is the star of the film
for such a young actress how much
gravitas she has how much emotion that
she brings to this dream
I mean the camera loves her and her
performance is absolutely spellbounding
if her performance didn't work the film
doesn't work
and it works great in her chemistry with
all the actors involved
Just Hits on so many levels Ken Watanabe
Tour De Forest once again one of the
best actors
in film today regardless Asian non-asian
let's put all that out of the way he's a
phenomenal actor and you're going to see
him just really shine in this movie
Allison Janny I haven't seen her in a
while she's been doing a lot more
television out there she is great in
this film I wanted to ask Eric that
interviewed him by the way but I only
had nine minutes with him so I could
only get so many questions out there but
I wanted to ask him why Alice and Jenny
be I mean she fits perfectly in this
film
but you just you don't think of her in
the beginning you're like how could you
not think of anybody else so the casting
in this movie is fantastic it is spot on
the performances the heart the right the
writing the pacing of this film there's
only one issue I have in this movie
that's towards the tail end of the third
act where it gets a little bit more
I don't want to say action adventure but
it gets a little bit more Tom Cruise and
the kind of the some sort of stunts at
the the John David Washington does just
for a moment but of course you are in
the future you've got to suspend a
little bit of belief but this movie
sticks the landing and it does in a big
way and that doesn't take you out of the
film in any way shape or form it's just
one of those things where you go okay
we're getting a little bit more Tom
Cruise in this portion of it but it's
only there for a little bit but the
emotion brings you back in and by the
end of this film some people are walking
out of the theater crying some people
are just in silence just thinking and
some people are clapping and it's that
kind of film that's going to bring all
those emotions into play
Gareth Edwards needs to be nominated for
something either Best Director best
story I don't know what he needs to be
nominated for something the
cinematography in his movies spot on
this visual effects are spot on
this movie doesn't miss a beat and I am
trying to I mean you've seen other
reviewers out there probably talking
about the same things I am but this is
one of the best films of 2023. I'll put
it up there with Oppenheimer and the
other ones out there it is that good you
definitely need to see this film support
Original Stories support original IPS I
don't know where this film is going to
go if there's going to be a sequel or
not I have no idea
even if it doesn't this movie will go
down as one of the Sci-Fi Classics of
the early 21st century in my personal
opinion anyway those are my thoughts on
the Creator let me know your thoughts in
the comment section below do you agree
with me if you've already seen the movie
if you have not love to hear from you as
well and with that if you want to see
more of our movie reviews check them out
right here